[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ल तो सबसे पहले
मुझे बता द सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है नहीं
यस या नो बता
दीजिए
तो एक मिनट वेट करते हैं बाकी लोग जवाइन
होने का उसके बाद हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
क्लास
को सब तक वेलकम टू डे 11 ऑफ बेस मास्टरी
कोर्स और जो आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं वह हम
क्या करेंगे कि कुछ नया टॉपिक नहीं है जो
डे थ्री से लेके आज तक हमने डे 10 तक जो
भी किया है बहुत सारे लोग बीच में जवाइन
किया है कुछ लोग स्टार्टिंग से पढ़ रहे
हैं तो उनको कंफ्यूज हो गया होगा कि हमने
क्याक पढ़ा है क्या क्या नहीं है तो एक
रिवीजन भी हो जाएगा और एक एग्जांपल के साथ
आपको क्लियर भी हो जाएगा कि कैसे चीजें
काम कर रही है कहां पर आप गलतियां करते हो
कैसे कौन सी गलती आपको कहां पर नहीं करनी
है जब आप स्क्रिप्ट लिख रहे हो खुद की तो
यह चीज आज हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं एक
रिवीजन हो जाएगा एक क्विक रिवीजन हो जाएगा
पूरी क्लास में और उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास
से हमारा एक नया टॉपिक स्टार्ट होगा और हम
अपनी स्क्रिप्टिंग की जर्नी स्टार्ट करने
जा रहे हैं फिर हमारा टोटली बेस्ट
स्क्रिप्टिंग ही स्टार्ट हो रहा
है तब तक एक मिनट वेट करते हैं बाकी लोगों
जवाइन होने
का
मुझे लगता है कि आज कोई नया जवाइन किया है
अनिल कुमार अ बताइए थोड़ा फर्स्ट डे है
क्या
आपका
तो चैट में बताइए आज आपका फर्स्ट डे है
क्या
चलो फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं ज्यादा
वेट नहीं करते हैं और टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करते हैं ओके तो आज हम क्या है रिवीजन
करने वाले हैं क्विक रिवीजन जो हमने पढ़ा
अभी तक का उसका रिवीजन करने वाले अभी से
डे थ्री से लेकर डे 10 तक जो भी मैंने अभी
तक आपको पढ़ाया है वो काफी इंपोर्टेंट है
और जो टॉपिक था हमारा हाउ बेस्ट प्रोसेसस
कमांड लाइंस वो काफी इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक है
व सक्सेसफुली हमारा लास्ट क्लास में उसको
हमने कंप्लीट कर दिया आज एक दो एग्जांपल
के साथ मैं आपको क्या करूंगा
आपको दो एग्जांपल के साथ आपको मैं क्या
करने वाला आपको शो करने वाला हूं तो
स्टार्ट करते हैं मैंने क्या क्या बताया
था सबसे पहले मैंने जो डे थ्री प आपको
पढ़ाया था वो कोटिंग पढ़ाया था कि कोटिंग
क्या होता है कि कोटिंग होती है कि किसी
भी कैरेक्टर का स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करने
का काम करती है किसी भी स्पेशल किसी भी
कैरेक्टर से उसका जो स्पेशल कैरेक्टर होता
है उसका एक स्पेशल मीनिंग होता है अगर हम
उसका स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करना तो उसके
लिए हम कोटिंग यूज करते हैं तीन टाइप्स की
कोट कोटिंग होती है बैक स्लस सिंगल कोट
डबल कोट बैक स्लस क्या करता है इमीडिएट उस
कक्टर का जो जहां पर उसको यूज किया जाए
उसके इमीडिएट कैरेक्टर का स्पेशल मीनिंग
रिमूव कर देता है सिंगल कोड क्या करता है
सिंगल कोड क्या करता है उसके अंदर जितने
भी कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं उनको उनके स्पेशल
मीनिंग को रिमूव कर देता है डबल कोट भी
सिंगल कोट की तरह ही काम करता है लेकिन
क्या करता है एक्सेप्ट डॉलर साइन एंड
बैटिस को यूज को छोड़ के बाकी सबका स्पेशल
मीनिंग क्या करता है रिमूव कर देता है अब
बात करते हैं जो भी कैरेक्टर्स का स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव हो जाता है उसको हम बोलते
हैं कोटेड या एस्केप कैरेक्टर यह था छोटा
सा टॉपिक नेक्स्ट जो हमारा टॉपिक हमने
पढ़ा था वो है स्टेप वन टोकेनाइजेशन प आ
जाते हैं टोकेनाइजेशन ये रहा टोकेनाइजेशन
क्या करता है कि टोकेनाइजेशन आपकी जो
कमांड लाइन है उसको चस के अंदर डिवाइड
करने काम करता है चस को टोकस भी बोल सकते
हैं और टोकस क्या सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैक्टस होते
हैं तो ये जो आपकी कमांड लाइन है उसको
ब्रेक करता है चंक्स में किसके बेस पर
मेटा कैक्टस के बेस पर जो 10 10 टाइप्स के
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं जो आपके स्क्रीन
के सामने दिखाई दे रहे होंगे ये र पाइप
सिंबल एंड ये सेमीकलन
ओपन
ब्रैकेट क्लोज ब्रैकेट फिर ये दो सिंबल और
स्पेस टैब न्यू लाइन ये 10 कैरेक्टर्स है
इनके बेसिस पर क्या करता है आपके कमांड
लाइन को ब्रेक करता है किसके किसम वर्ड्स
और ऑपरेटर के अंदर आपकी कमांड लाइन को
वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर में ब्रेक करता है
वर्ड्स वर्ड्स क्या है दोस टोकन आर
डिफाइंड ए वट डज नॉट कंटेन एनी अनकोटेड
मेटा कक्टर मतलब वर्ड्स हम उनको बोलेंगे
सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स जो जिसके अंदर एक
भी मेटा कैरेक्टर्स नहीं है अनकोटेड जिसके
अंदर एक भी अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है
उसको हम वर्ड्स बोलते हैं ऑपरेटर्स हम
किसको बोलते हैं एटलीस्ट जिसके अंदर एक
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है उसको हम बोलते
हैं ऑपरेटर्स तो इन इन दो पार्ट में
डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है आपकी कमांड लाइन
को को एक बार रफ आईडिया लेने के बाद
वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर के अंदर नेक्स्ट जो
ऑपरेटर्स होता है उसके दो टाइप्स होते हैं
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर होता है एक रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर होता है कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर क्या करता
है होता है कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कौन-कौन से
होते हैं न्यू लाइन पाइप सिंबल डबल पाइप
एम पर डबल एम परसेंट सेमीकलन डबल सेमीकलन
उसके बाद सेमीकलन एम पर डबल सेमीकलन एम पर
पाइप सिंबल एम परट नेक्स्ट ओपन ब्रैकेट
क्लोज ब्रैकेट ये आपके कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स
होते हैं और उसके जिसके बेस प आपके कमांड
क्या ब्रेक होती है आपकी कमांड को क्या वो
कर दिया जाता है ब्रेक कर कर दिया जाता है
आपके कमांड लाइन को एंड कर दिया जाता है
बेसिकली इनका आपको पता कंट्रोल करने का
काम करते है आपके कमांड को ये डायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर क्या करते
डायरेक्शन का काम करते हैं कि आपका आउटपुट
किसी फाइल का इनपुट बनेगा या टर्मिनल पर आ
किसी फाइल के अंदर सेव होगा डायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर य होते हैं ग्रेटर देन सिंबल लेसन
सिंबल डबल ग्रेटर देन डबल लेसन ये सारे
क्या डायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर होते य सब हमने
पढ़ा था उसके बाद हमने पढ़ा था नेक्स्ट
डायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के बाद जो हम चलते हैं
सो टोकना के बाद जो हमने पढ़ा था कंट्रोल
च करते हैं
यार
उसके बाद जो हमने पढ़ा था यह रहा कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन जब एक बार टोकेनाइजेशन
स्टेप परफॉर्म हो जाता है उसके बाद कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन होता है दो टाइप्स की
कमांड्स होती है आपको पता है सिंपल कमांड
होती है कंपाउंड कमांड होती है और आपको
पहले आपको पता है कि सिंपल कमांड कहां से
स्टार्ट होती है कहां पर फिनिश होती है और
कंपाउंड कमांड कहां से स्टार्ट होती है
कहां पर फिनिश होती है सिंपल कमांड्स
बेसिकली जो कोई भी सिंपल कमांड होती है वो
क्या करती है जो उसको टर्मिनेट किया जाता
है विद द हेल्प ऑफ कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स
कंपाउंड कमांड कहां से स्टार्ट होती है
कंपाउंड कमांड स्टार्ट होती है आपकी आपकी
एक रिजर्व वर्ड से स्टार्ट होती है और उसी
से उसी से एंड होगी जो भी रिजर्व है जैसे
कि वाइ लूप्स है आपके फोर लूप्स है और इफ
कंडीशंस है वो सारे कंपाउंड कमांड्स के
अंदर आते हैं तो दो ये कंपाउंड कमांड्स है
आपकी फॉर एग्जांपल ये रहा इफ इससे स्टार्ट
हुई कंपाउंड कंपाउंड्स देन और प पे ही
खत्म होता है ये पूरी पूरी कंपाउंड कमांड
और इसके अंदर फिर आपकी सिंपल कमांड्स
परफॉर्म होती है तो ये आपका कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन था कि कमांड एडिफिकेशन
सिंपल कंपाउंड सिंपल कमांड्स और कंपाउंड
कमांड्स के अंदर डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है
नेक्स्ट जो हमने स्टेप थ्री पढ़ा था स्टेप
थ्री एक्सपेंशन के बारे में पढ़ा था जिसको
हम बोलते हैं सेल एक्सपेंशन या
एक्सपेंशन जब एक बार आपका टोकेनाइजेशन
स्टेप कंप्लीट हो जाता था उसके बाद जो सेल
एक्सपेंशन था ये जो एक्सपेंशन था ये आपका
जो वर्ड्स थे क्योंकि हमने टोकना स्टेप
में वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर के अंदर डिवाइड किया
था कमांड लाइन को तो जो आपके वर्ड्स थे
उसके ऊपर परफॉर्म किया जाता है सेल
एक्सपेंशन को अब सेल एक्सपेंशन की चार
स्टेज होती है स्टेज वन होती है ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन स्टेज टू होती है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन डेड एक्सपेंशन स्टेज स्टेज दो
टू के अंदर ये चार एक्सपेंशस आते हैं
स्टेज थ्री के अंदर वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग आता
है स्टेज फोर के अंदर ग्लोबिंग आता है और
सबसे पहली ये चीज मैं आपको बताया था कि कि
फर्स्ट थिंग यू नीड टू नो द ट एक्सपेंशन
अर्ली स्टेज आम कि स्टेज जो स्टेज के
अकॉर्डिंग जैसे मैंने लिस्ट आपको सामने शो
करी है इसके अकॉर्डिंग जो पहले आएगा उसको
परफॉर्म किया जाएगा फर्स्ट प्रायोरिटी उसी
की है सबसे पहले अगर पहले ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन
आया तो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन मतलब पहले ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन को ही परफॉर्म किया जाएगा भले
ही आपने स्टार्टिंग में वर्स स्लिटिंग
किया हुआ ओके नेक्स्ट ये एग्जांपल शो किया
था नो सेकंड कंडीशन कती थी सेकंड थिंग यू
नीड टू नो इज दैट एक्सपेंशन दैट आर इन द
सेम स्टेजेस आर ऑल आर गिवन सेम प्रायोरिटी
एंड आर सिंपली परफॉर्म इन ऑर्डर दे फाउंड
ऑन द कमांड लाइन व्हेन इट रीड फ्रॉम लेफ्ट
टू राइट होता क्या है कि जो
अ जो स्टेज टू है स्टेज टू में क्या है
प्रायोरिटी सबकी सेम है सबकी सेम
प्रायोरिटी है तो आपका क्या होता है जो भी
कमांड होती है आपकी तो वो लेफ्ट टू राइट
परफॉर्म की जाती है लेफ्ट टू राइट ऐसे ले
टू राइट आप परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं तो मैंने
यह बताया था कि अगर स्टेज टू में सभी का
सभी का जो क्या है पटी सेम है तो लेफ्ट टू
राइट में जो पहले आएगा स्टेज टू के अंदर
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन में अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन में क इनम से जो पहले आएगा उसको
पहले परफॉम किया क्यों प्रायोरिटी सेम है
तो लेफ्ट टू राइट में अगर पहले पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन आ तो पहले पैटर एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म किया जाएगा टट एक्सपेंशन आ तो
एक्स परफॉर्म किया जाएगा ये दो कंडीशन के
साथ मैंने सेल एक्सपेंशन को बताया था
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन क्या है होता है कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन क्या होता है टिल एक्सपेंशन
क्या होता है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग क्या होता
है ग्लोबिंग ये सब मैं आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं
और मैंने बताया था कि पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
क्या किसको बोलते हैं जो भी वेरिएबल होते
हैं ये रहा पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन क्या होता
है वेरिएबल आपको पता है पैरामीटर क्या
होता है एंटिटी होती है और वेरिएबल आपको
बता चुका हूं जो वैल्यू को स्टोर करने का
काम करते हैं दो टाइप के वेरिएबल होते हैं
सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल होते हैं जिनको
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल भी बोलते हैं यूजर
डिफाइंड वेरिएबल हो जो किसी भी यूजर के
द्वारा डिफाइन किए जाते हैं ये वेरिएबल
कैसे करना है मैं आपको क्लास में बता चुका
हूं ये हमारी डे कौन सी क्लास है डे सिक्स
की क्लास है देन सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल
होते हैं जो सिस्टम के द्वारा डिफाइन किए
जाते हैं और पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन किसको
किसको बोला जाता है जब आपने एक वेरिएबल
डिफाइन कर दिया जब उसकी वैल्यू को हमने
क्या करना पता रेफरेंस लेना पड़ता है तो
उसके लिए जो सही तरीका होता है वो होता है
आपका पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन उसी को हम
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन बोलते हैं बेसिकली
डॉलर सिंबल करली बेसस के अंदर जो वैल्यू
को हम फैच करते हैं रेफरेंस लेते हैं ये
रहा डाटा को यहां से लिया उसके बाद डाटा
को आउट कर दिया रेफरेंस के एक पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन होता होता है ये रहा ऐसे
स्टूडेंट है एक नितेश स्टूडेंट है उसका
वेरिएबल का नाम है एकको किया डॉलर
स्टूडेंट उसके बाद कली बसे क्लोज कर दिया
ये एक पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है ये क्या करता
है इसकी वैल्यू जो पैरामीटर की वैल्यू
उसके साथ रिप्लेस कर देता है एक पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो गया नेक्स्ट चलते
हैं
हमने नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं जो हमने
पढ़ा था पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन हम पढ़ चुके
हैं उसके बाद मैंने कुछ क्वेश्चंस दिए थे
आपको अगर आपको आंसर इसके मालूम नहीं है तो
मैं आपको बता देता हूं एट द एंड वैसे अभी
बताऊंगा तो आपने अभी तक किए नहीं वैसे चलो
कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन की बात करते हैं कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन क्या होता है बेसिकली उसका जो
सिंटेक्स होता है डॉलर ओपन ब्रैकेट उसके
बाद अंदर कमांड कमांड सबट बेसिकली क्या
करता है कि हम उसके अंदर कोई भी कमांड दे
देते हैं कमांड का जो भी आउटपुट होता है
उसको वो वहां पर उसको परफॉर्म करता है और
उसके आउटपुट को उसके जगह वल्य उस वैल्यू
में रिप्लेस करता है जैसे ये रहा ये कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन है डॉलर कमांड अब यहां पर जो
इसके अंदर जो कमांड देंगे कमांड का जो भी
आउटपुट हो इसको पूरी के रिप्लेस कर देगा
और एक और अच्छी बात है कमा सब्सीट्यूशन की
हम किसी भी वेरिएबल के अंदर इसकी वैल्यू
को स्टोर कर सकते हैं ये एक अच्छा तरीका
है कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन का तो अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है बेसिकली कैलकुलेशन
परफॉर्म करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन का यूज करते हैं और
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन ओनली वोल नंबर के ऊपर
काम करती है डेसीमल नंबर के ऊपर काम नहीं
करती डेसीमल नंबर के ऊपर काम करने के लिए
हम बीसी कमांड के साथ ही अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन उसको परफॉर्म करते हैं ओके ये
समझ में आ गया होगा ये था कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन नेक्स्ट
मैंने जब बताया था आपको रिवीजन है ये रहा
नेक्स्ट जो मैंने बताया था ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है और वर्स प्लेटिंग
क्या होता है वर्स प्लेटिंग में बताता हूं
देखो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग एक एक प्रो वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग इज अ प्रोसेस परफॉर्म बाय सेल
ऑन द रिजल्ट ऑफ सम ऑफ द एक्सपेंशन टू
सेपरेट दो सेपरेट व देखो क्या होता है कि
जो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग है एक ऐसी प्रोसेस है
जो सेल के द्वारा परफॉर्म की जाती है
किसके कुछ एक्सपेंशस होते हैं कौन-कौन से
एक्सपेंशन होते हैं पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन और अर्थमेटिक सभी
एक्सपेंशन के आउटपुट में परफॉर्म नहीं कि
रता है ओनली जो अन जो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
है जो कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन है और अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन इन तीनों का जो आउटपुट आगा
आउटपुट आएगा वो भी अनकोटेड आउटपुट होना
चाहिए मतलब कोटेड नहीं होना चाहिए कोटिंग
मैं बता चुका हूं क्या होता है तो जो
आउटपुट आए वो अनकोटेड होना चाहिए तो उसी
के ऊपर इसको क्या किया जाता है परफॉर्म
किया जाता है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग को और वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग भी क्या करती है कि आपका जो
टोकेनाइजेशन की तरह रेफरेंस है
टोकेनाइजेशन भी कैरेक्टर्स का रेफरेंस
लेता है वो मेटा कैरेक्टर रेफरेंस लेता है
लेकिन जो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग है जो जो लिस्ट
ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स को फॉलो करती है वो कौन सी
होती है आईएफएस वेरिएबल आईएफस वेरिएबल के
अंदर इंटरनल फीड सेपरेटर होता है बाय
डिफॉल्ट उसके अंदर स्पेस न्यू लांड टैब्स
होते हैं आप चाहे तो उसकी वैल्यू को चेंज
भी कर सकते हैं लेकिन आईएफएस वेरिएबल के
अंदर जो भी कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं लिस्ट ऑफ
कैरेक्टर्स होती है उसी को रेफर लेके आपके
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग का परफॉर्म किया जाता है
लेकिन टोकेनाइजेशन में कैसे परफॉर्म किया
जाता था टोकेनाइजेशन में 10 मेटा कैरेक्टर
के बेसिस पर उसको परफॉर्म किया जाता था ये
था हमारा आपका वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग जब बात
करते हैं अब हम ओके ओके ओके इसमें और कुछ
नहीं था नेक्स्ट जो मैंने बताया था आपको
ये
रहा ग्लोबिंग देखो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन आपको
बता चुका था ब्रेस एक्सशन कुछ एडवांस
टॉपिक है अब बात करते थे हम ग्लोबिंग
ग्लोबिंग ग्लोबिंग ग्लोबिंग क्या होता है
देखो ग्लोबिंग क्या होता है ग्लोबिंग इ
आल्सो नोन फाइल नेम एक्सपेंशन हम बोलते
हैं ये ग्लो प्रोग्राम से ओरिजनेट किया जा
था जो बेल लब्स के अंदर 1969 1975 और जो
ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है ओनली वर्ड्स
के ऊपर परफॉर्म की जाती है और सेल क्या
करता है ये जब भी वर्ड्स मिलता है उसके
अंदर स्कैनिंग करता है स्कैनिंग में इन
तीन कैरेक्टर्स को ढूंढता है एस्टिक्स
क्वेश्चन मार्क और ओपन ब्रैकेट यह जहां भी
मिल जाता वहीं पर उसे लगता कि आप पर
ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म करनी है उसको ग्लोबिंग
परफॉर्म करता है व भी अनकोटेड होने चाहिए
भी कोटेड नहीं होने चाहिए कोटेड होंगे तो
तब भी ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म नहीं होगी क्योंकि
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स होते है स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर दिया
जाता है उसके बाद स्टेप फोर आता है स्टेप
फोर में हमने पढ़ा था कोट रिमूवल स्टेप
फोर में हमने पढ़ा था कोट रिमूवल अब कोट
रिमूवल आप आपको पता है कि कोट कोटिंग
क्यों यूज करते हैं कोटिंग हम तब यूज करते
थे जब हमें किसी स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स का
मीनिंग रिमूव करना हो जब एक बार हमने कभी
किसी स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स का मीनिंग रिमूव
कर दिया तो उसके बाद हमें कोटिंग की जरूरत
थोड़ी ना है उन कैरेक्टर्स की बैक स्लैश
सिंगल कोट डबल कोट की जरूरत थोड़ी ना तो
इसलिए हम कोट रिमूवल यूज करते हैं अब कोट
रिमूवल की एक कंडीशन है वो कैसे काम करता
है ड्यूरिंग कोट रिमूवल द सेल रिमूवस ऑल द
अनकोटेड बैकलेस सिंगल कोट एंड डबल कोट
कैरेक्टर्स दैट डिड नॉट रिजल्ट फ्रॉम ए
सेल एक्सपेंशन मत बेसिकली क्या है कि सेल
किसको रिमूव करेगा कोट रिमूवल के दौरान
सारे अनकोटेड बैक स्लेस सिंगल कोट डबल कोट
कैक्टस डिड नॉट रिज फम देख दो कंडीशन है
एक तो जो बैकलेस है सिंगल कोट है डबल कोट
है वो कोटेड नहीं होने चाहिए अनकोटेड होना
चाहिए तभी उनको रिमूव करेगा दूसरी कंडीशन
ये है कि वो किसी भी सेल एक्सपेंशन का कोई
भी सेल एक्सपेंशन कौन से होते हैं ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन स्ड एक्सपेंशन ये जो भी है
जितने भी एक्सपेंशन अभी मैंने बताया रा
स्टेप थ्री में उनका किसी का भी आउटपुट
नहीं होना चाहिए अगर उनके किसी का भी
आउटपुट होगा तब भी आपका कोट रिमूवल नहीं
होगा और एग्जांपल के साथ में मैंने आपको
बताया था कि कोट रिमूवल कैसे होता है तो
आपको पता चल गया कि जो कोट रिमूवल है
अनकोटेड बैक्स लेस सिंगल कोट और डबल कोट
अनकोटेड हैय भी सब उन्हीं के ऊपर परफॉर्म
किया जाता है दूसरा वो किसी भी सेल
एक्सपेंशन का आउटपुट होना नहीं चाहिए सेल
एक्सपेंशन कौन से होते है आपको बताया अभी
अभी जस्ट अभी आपको रिपीट किया पैरामीटर
ब्रेस टेल डेट कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन ग्लोबिंग
ये वड वर्ड स्लिटिंग ये सारे एक्सपेंशन के
अंदर आते हैं ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन इनका आउटपुट
नहीं होना चाहिए आउटपुट में नहीं होना
चाहिए नेक्स्ट आपका स्टेप फाइव आता है
रीडायरेक्शन जो नेक्स्ट आता है आपका स्टेप
फाइव रीडायरेक्शन रीडायरेक्शन में आपको
पहले बताया था मैं आपको एक रेफरेंस भी
दिया था आपको क्या करना है डे फोर में
जाना है हमारा काली प्लेलिस्ट में तो आप
वहां से क्या कर सकते हो इसको पढ़ सकते हो
बेसिक डायरेक्शन का काम क्या है कि आपका
जो भी आउटपुट आएगा क्योंकि आपने जब कमांड
परफॉर्म उसका कोई ना कोई आउटपुट आएगा क्या
वो किसी फाइल का फाइल का इनपुट होगा या
किसी फाइल के अंदर स्टोर होगा या किसी
कमांड का इनपुट होगा या आपका टर्मिनल पर
शो होगा या और कहां जाएगा तो वो सारी
चीजें आपके डायरेक्शन के अंदर अगर कोई एरर
आई तो एरर कहां प शो होगी टर्मिनल पर शो
होगी बाय डिफॉल्ट टर्मिनल प होती है या
उसको कहीं रीडायरेक्ट करना है किसी फाइल
के अंदर डायरेक्ट कर तो वो सार डायरेक्शन
है जब एक बार पाच स्टेप परफॉर्म कर दिए
जाते हैं उसके बाद आता है आपका
एग्जीक्यूशन स्टेप उसके बाद एग्जीक्यूट कर
दिया जाता है यहां तक था डे 10 आज हम बात
करने वाले एग्जांपल के
साथ ी मैं आपको दो एग्जांपल लूंगा और
एग्जांपल में हो सकता टाइम लगे बट आपको आज
पूरा क्लियर हो
जाएगा डे
चलो एग्जांपल के साथ हम चलने वाले पहले
इधर ही चलेंगे हम ताकि आपको बिल्कुल
क्लियर हो जाए चीज का वन बाय वन एग्जांपल
के साथ मैं आपको बताता
हूं ये
रहा फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है देखिए
हमारे पास एक कमांड है मेरे पास एक कमांड
है मैं आपको लिख देता हूं कि स्क्रीन के
सामने ये रहा मेरे पास एक ये कमांड है एको
उसके बाद मैंने लिखा डॉलर उसके बाद मैंने
लिखा नेम देन उसके बाद ग्रेटर देन सिंबल
देन स्पेस उसके बाद डॉलर आउट डॉलर आउट फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने एक और चीज लिया
जो डॉलर नेम है यह इनका कुछ भी नेम हो
सकता डलर नेम में कुछ भी आ सकता कोई भी
वैल्यू तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं देखो अब
यह एक कमांड है इसके ऊपर मुझे यह मैंने
अपने टर्मिनल में या अपने सेल के ऊपर
मैंने लिखा इस कमांड को टर्मिनल सेल के
ऊपर क्या किया रा डाउन किया आपको जूम कर
देता हूं य रहा बोल्ड कर देते य रहा आपकी
य कमांड है अभी सबसे पहला स्टेप होगा व
परफॉर्म किया जाए मैं काम आपको थोड़ा सा
और क्लियर हो जाएगा कर देता हूं नेम इक्वल
टू लिख देते हैं हम
सचिन सचिन देन जो आउट आउट में आएगा आउटपुट
फाइल लेगा ये डेमो डेमो
डॉट टी एक्सटी लिया डेमो डटी एक्सटी
ओके डेमो डटी एक्सटी ये है आपकी कमांड ओके
अब क्या होगा बेसिकली ये तो वेरिएबल है अब
हम क्या कर रहे हैं इसको दिखा रहा हूं
आपको कि कैसे ये प्रोसेस करेगा आपके कमांड
लाइन के अंदर ये कमांड आपने डाउन की तो
सबसे पहला क्या होगा टोकना परफॉर्म किया
जाएगा जब टोकना परफॉर्म कर दिया जाएगा तो
आपको पता है टोकेनाइजेशन में मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं यह
रहा कंट्रोल जड
यार ओके सबसे पहले क्या टोक परफॉर्म किया
जाएगा तो यहां पर आपको पता है देखो एक
उसके बाद आ गया एक स्पेस स्पेस का एक मेटा
कैरेक्टर है उसके बाद डॉलर नेम डॉलर एक
मेटा कक्टर नहीं है क्योंकि 10 का अंदर
इसका नाम नहीं आ उसके बाद स्पेस उसके बाद
फिर आ गया ग्रेटर देन सिंबल उसके बाद क्या
आया फिर आपका ये स्पेस आया उसके बाद आउट
डॉलर आउट अब यह अब यहां पर आपको मैं बताता
हूं अगर आपकी बात बात करें य रहा
चलो
यहा तो यहां पर क्या है जो अनकोटेड मेटा
जो अन कोटेड फर अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर
अनकोटेड होने चाहिए
अन य ओटी अनकोटेड जो मेटा कक्टर
है अनकोटेड मैक्ट की बात करता हूं कौन कन
से य पर सबसे पहले ी स्पेस ी स्पेस
एंड वन डायरेक्शन रेटर न ग्रेटर सिंबल ये
वन ग्रेटर देन सिंबल ये आपके अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स है
अब आपकी आपने क्या कि टॉक स्टेप में इनको
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
हो यह भी एक वर्ड है उसके बाद आपका आएगा
डॉलर नेम यह भी आपका एक वर्ड है एन ए एम ई
यह भी एक वर्ड हो गया उसके बाद आपका डॉलर
आउट यह भी एक वर्ड हो गया यह तीन वर्ड हो
ग आपके यह तीन वर्ड हो ग वर्ड हो ग आपके
इसको क्या करता कलर चेंज करता आपके सामने
इसका य हो ग तीन वर्ड्स नेक्स्ट बात करते
हैं हम अब ऑपरेटर कौन सा हो गया अब बात
करते हम ऑपरेटर्स की
तो ऑपरेटर अब ऑपरेटर यहां पर हो गया ओनली
एक ही ऑपरेटर हुआ देखो स्पेस है और ग्रेटर
दन सिंबल है तो ऑपरेटर के अंदर आ गया
ग्रेटर दन सिंबल आपका क्या है यह है एक
ऑपरेटर आपका यह है एक ऑपरेटर ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल यह आपका एक ऑपरेटर यह आपका एक
ऑपरेटर यह आपका एक ऑपरेटर है जब एक बार
आपने क्या कर लिया वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर में
डिवाइड हो गया तो उसके बाद होता है कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन ये था आपका स्टेप वन आपका
ये स्टेप वन परफॉर्म हो गया इसके बाद क्या
होगा आपका कमांड इफिकेशन जब कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन होगा आपको पता है कि सेल
सेल क्या करता है सिंपल कमांड और कंपाउंड
कमांड्स में आईडेंटिफाई करता है सिंपल क
कमांड्स और कंपाउंड कमांड अब सिंपल
कमांड्स क्या होती है वो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
से क्या की जाती है टर्मिनेट की जाती है
जो सिंपल कमांड्स होती है वो जो कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर है उसी से उसको टर्मिनेट किया जाता
है अब कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कौन-कौन से होते हैं
आपको पता है देखो ये आपके कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
मैं अगर बात करता हूं ये रहे कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर इ द कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर ये रही र
ये रहा मैं काम कर दिया
इसको ये रहा ये आपका कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर न्यू
लाइन ये तो क्या एक बात बताओ क्या इनमें
से कोई भी कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर है नहीं वहां पर
कोई भी कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं है मतलब वहां
पर कोई कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं आपको दिखाई दे
रहा तो रीडायरेक्शन जो सिंबल है गट सिंबल
एक रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर है ये क्या है एक
रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर है जब आपका कंपाउंड
कमांड्स हुई जब आपका स्टेप टू हुआ जबका
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन हुआ कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
जब स्टेप टू हुआ स्टेप टू में आप कमांड
होआ
कमांड कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन जब आपका कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन तो इसको क्या किया पूरी की
पूरी कमांड को एक सिंपल कंट्रोल सी करता
हूं और ये
रहा कंट्रोल बी अब ये क्या है पूरी की
पूरी सिंगल कमांड ये क्या कर दिया
इन्होंने एक
इसको एक सिंपल कंपाउंड कंसीडर कर ली एक
सिंपल कमांड कंसीडर किया इसको एज ए सिंपल
कमांड कंसीडर क्योंकि कंपाउंड कमांड नहीं
है कंपाउंड क स्टार्ट होती है एक रिजर्व
वर्ड्स से जो आपके लॉजिकल वाले वर्ड्स है
लेकिन ये एक सिंपल कमांड कंसीडर क्योंकि
यहां पर कोई भी कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं है
इसलिए बाय डिफॉल्ट इसका जो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
है य न्यू लाइन कक्टर से इसको एंड किया
जाता है टर्मिनेट किया जाता है तो यहां पर
टर्मिनेट करने के लिए कोई भी कंट्रोल टर
नहीं है इसलिए यहां पे एज इसको सिंपल कम
एक सिंपल एक सिंगल सिंपल कमांड इसको
कंसीडर किया मैं इसको एक काम कर लेता हूं
ो कर देता हूं नॉट रिक्वायर्ड ये रहा ये
रहा ये
रहा इसको हम क्या करते य स एक सिंपल
कंपाउंड कमांड इसको कंसीडर किया गया है
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं अब हम स्टेप स्टेप थ्री
हो गया आपका कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन अब बात
करते हैं हम स्टेप थ्री स्टेप टू हो गया
अब बात करते हम स्टेप थ्री में क्या होगा
स्टेप जो थ्री आपका अरे यार
आपका स्टेप थ यहां पर जो होगा ट द इशू
प्रो आपका स्टेप थ्री होगा उसकी बात करता
हूं मैं वो आपका एक्सपेंशन है प एक्स प
स्टेप थ में एक्सपेंशन आपका एक्सपेंशन आते
हैंकी चार स्टेज होती है एक्सपेंशन की
आपको वो भी पता है उसकी होती है चार
स्टेजेस होती है एक्सपेंशन की तो अब यहां
पर आप ही बताइए यहां पर कि ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन तो है नहीं यहां पर ना कोई
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन है ऊपर से क्या है कि हां
यहां पर ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन नहीं है लेकिन
यहां पर क्या है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है
यहां पर पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है कितने है
दो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन है तो यहां पर परफॉर्म किया
जाएगा पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन को और पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म किया जाएगा तो देखो
एकको कर रहा हूं यहां पर आएगा एकको ए सी
एओ एक पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है तो डॉलर नेम
की जगह क्या आएगा सचिन एसे सी एच आई ए एस
ए सी एच सचिन लिखा जाएगा देन ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल नेक्स्ट आउटपुट डॉलर आउटपुट डॉलर
आउट क्या है आपका डेमो डी एमओ डेमो डटी
एक्टी डेमो डटी एक्टी अब क्या है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन के अलावा आपको लगता है कि कोई
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन है कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
है या टेलेट एक्सपेंशन है कुछ भी नहीं है
इसका मतलब नेक्स्ट आपका जो स्टेज स्टेप
थ्री में स्टेज थ्री आती थी व्हा इ द वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग क्या यहां पर कोई भी वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग है कोई भी वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
नहीं हो रही क्योंकि वर्स स्प्लिटिंग
किसके ऊपर परफॉर्म की जाती है वर्स
स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है रिजल्ट ऑफ
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक क बट क्या
है वो भी अनकोटेड होना चाहिए आउटपुट दूसरा
क्या है कि वो किसको रेफरेंस करता है वड
स्प्लिटिंग वड स्प्लिटिंग रेफर करता है
आईएफएस वेरिएबल और आईएफएस वेरिएबल की
वैल्यू यहां पर क्या है स्पेस टैब और न्यू
लाइन यहां पर आपको कोई भी जो ये रहा
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन की वैल्यू में स्पेस
टैब न्यू लाइन है नहीं तो यहां पर कोई भी
वर्ड स्लिटिंग भी नहीं है तो मतलब नो वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग
नो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
नो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग ओके ना ना तो कोई वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग है और क्या आपको लगता है कोई
ग्लोबिंग है आपको ना ही कोई ग्लोबिंग है
क्या ग्लोबिंग क्या है अब ये वर्ड है
ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है वर्ड्स के
ऊपर अब ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म करने वर्ड आ गया
क्या इसके अंदर आपको कोई भी वो तीन पैटर्न
दिखाई दे रहे हैं स्टार क्वेश्चन मार्क और
ओपन ब्रैकेट्स क्या व तीनों पैटन यहां पर
किसी को दिखाई दे रहे हैं नहीं इसका मतलब
क्या है य पर ग्लोबिंग भी नहीं है नो
ग्लोबिंग नो ग्लोबिंग ना ही कोई ग्लोबिंग
है ना ही यहां पर व स्प्लिटिंग हो रही है
ना ही कोई ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन है ना ही
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन है ना ही
कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन है ओनली क्या है आपका
परफॉर्म हो रहा है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन तो
आपकी स्टेज थ्री भी कंप्लीट होगी आपकी
स्टेज थ्री भी कंप्लीट हो गई ये
रहा ये आपका स्टेज थ्री यहां पर आपका
स्टेज थ्री भी कंप्लीट हो गया नेक्स्ट
चलते हैं हम आपका स्टेप
स्टेप स्टेप फोर आएगा स्टेप फोर आपका क्या
आता है कोट रिमूवल
यू कोट रिमूवल कोट रिमूवल आपका ये आता है
कोट रिमूवल क्या आप लोगों को लगता है यहां
पर कोट रिमूवल हो रहा है क्योंकि यहां पर
कोई भी कोट है ही नहीं कोट रिमूव कहीं भी
आपको क्या डबल कोट सिंगल कोट या बैक स्लस
दिखाई दे रहा नहीं मतलब यहां पर कोई भी
कोड रिमूवल नहीं है तो ये एज इट इज आएगा
आपको कंट्रोल सी यहां पर ये रहा कंट्रोल
बी मतलब नो कोट रिमूवल मतलब नो कोट
रिमूवल नो
कोट
रिमूवल अब नो कोट
रिमूवल य पर कोई भी कोट रिमूवल नहीं हो
रहा ओके अब बात आते है स्टेप फ डायरेक्शन
की बात बात करते डाय डायरेक्शन होगा य पर
अब इसका आउटपुट होगा स्टेप फ की बात करते
हैं हम
रीडायरेक्शन डायरेक्शन अब बात करते
डायरेक्शन डायरेक्शन में क्या होगा य पर
डायरेक्शन होगा देखो जो सन इसका पर ट कर
रहा है मतलब जोय कमांड है आपकी मैं आपको
दिखा
देता एस ए सीई सचिन मतलब ये कमांड है अब
इसका जो एसटीडी आउटपुट है बता रहा एडी इस
कमांड को करता बकेट में लेता
इसको
यहा य रहा य कमांड है आपकी कमांड हैय अब
इसका जो आउटपुट आएगा इसका आट जाएगा ड परम
हो रहा है
इसका ये परफॉर्म होगा आपका इधर इसका जोय
एसडी आउट है इसके परर बात करर हूं अगर
मैं एसटीडी ओ यूटी एसटीडी आउट कहां जाएगा
इसका एटीडी आउट कहां जाएगा बताइए इसका एडी
आउट जाएगा यह
रहा ये रहा इसका स्टडी आउट कहां पर जा रहा
है
के अंदर एडी आउट जाएगा इसका इधर आउटपुट
डटी एक्सटी के
अंदर आउटपुट डटी
एक्टी आपको दिखा यहां
पर
यहा आ नहीं आउटपुट नहीं सॉरी डेमो डेमो
डटी एक्सटी डेमो एक्स के अंदर जाहा ये रहा
इसका जो डायरेक्शन यहां पर आ रहा है
डायरेक्शन यहां पर इसका तो इसका मतलब
आउटपुट कहां आ स्टोर होगा इसका डेमो के
अंदर जब आप उसको कैट करोगे तो डेमो
एक्स के अंदर इसका आउटपुट देखने को मिलेगा
तो ये क्या हुआ आपका पाच स्टेप आपको सामने
मैंने परफॉर्म कि य फाइव स्टेप परफॉर्म
किए सबसे पहले स्टेप य टोकना य रहा यहां
पर क्या किया स्टेप
वन स्टेप वन टोकेनाइजेशन
एन
आई टोकेनाइजेशन ये आपका स्टेप वन है
टोकेनाइजेशन उसके बाद स्टेप टू परफॉर्म
किया इधर कमांड स्टेप थ परफॉर्म किया
एक्सपेंशन स्टेप फोर परफॉर्म किया कोड
रिमूवल स्टेप फाइ परफॉर्म किया मैंने आपके
सामने एक
मिनट य रहा क्या इ हो
गया य
रहा हमने परफॉर्म किया इधर ये रहा आपका
डायरेक्शन तो एक और नया एग्जांपल ले आपके
सामने में एक और नया एग्जांपल मैं थ लास्ट
और फाइनल एग्जांपल जो आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर
कर देगा अभी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग एग्जांपल है
स्क्रिप्टिंग के साथ अबकी बार ये
रहा अभी क्या है कि आपको क्या करना है एक
स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी है स्क्रिप्ट का एम क्या
है कि आपको यूजर नेम है और वो आपका लास्ट
नेम है यूजर नेम और लास्ट नेम दोनों को
डॉट के साथ आपने क्या किया हुआ है लिखा
हुआ है तो उन दोनों को सेपरेट करना है और
किसी एक फाइल के अंदर उसको स्टोर करना और
वो फाइल कहां पर स्टोर होनी चाहिए आपकी
होम डायरेक्टरी
पहली बात आपका एम क्या है एक स्क्रिप्ट
लिखनी है स्क्रिप्ट में आपको क्या करना है
उसमें एक यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड है जो
वेरिएबल है उस और यूजरनेम पासवर्ड क्या है
डॉट के साथ दिए हुए हैं और उनको क्या करना
है सेपरेट करना है सेपरेट करके एक आउटपुट
फाइल है आउटपुट डटी उसके अंदर उसको स्टोर
करना है और और वो फाइल कहां पर स्टोर होनी
चाहिए आपकी होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर स्टोर
होना चाहिए तो उसके लिए मैंने क्या कर
दिया स्क्रिप्टिंग लिखनी स्टार्ट कर दी
चलो मैं इधर लिख के दिखाता हूं क्योंकि
आपको एक्सप्लेन करना है ना इधर ये रहा तो
सबसे पहले मैं ऊपर लिखूंगा सी बैंक पार्ट
बैंक पार्ट लिखूंगा य रहा स्ल बिन स्ल बस
मैंने लिखा सबसे पहले यह पार्ट देन उसके
बाद मैं क्या लिखता हूं क्योंकि मुझे आईस
वेरिएबल की वैल्यू चेंज करनी होगी ना
क्योंकि आस में मुझे क्या कर देना है डबल
कोट उसके बाद मुझे डॉट सेपरेटेड करना है य
मैंने दे दिया डॉट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट मैं
लिखता हूं आपको नेम नेम लिखा मैंने इक्वल
लिखा और मैं लिखा सचिन डॉट उसके बाद लिखा
सि एस आई एन जी एच लिखा ओके देन मुझे
मैंने क्या क्या किया आपका आउट ओ यटी
आउट आउट जो है वेरिएबल है उसको मैंने क्या
कर दिया उसको भी मैंने क्या कर दिया ऊपर
से जो वेरिएबल ये रहा आपका डॉलर ने ये भी
क्या है उसके अंदर डबल कोट के अंदर य डबल
कोट के अंदर और यह भी मैंने डबल कोट के
अंदर य आउटपुट डॉटी एक आपको पता है बहुत
इजी तरीके से इन परफॉर्म कर दिया जाएगा ये
तो आप बता नहीं आउटपुट ड एक्टी नेक्स्ट अब
आप बोलोगे ठीक है सिंपल है मुझे लिखना
लिखने में क्या प्रॉब्लम है सिंपली मुझे
लिखने
सिंपल मुझे लिखने में क्या प्रॉब्लम है
मुझे सिंपली लिखने में कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
ठीक है मैं सिंपली ऐसे कर देता हूं को
कोको उसके बाद मैंने क्या लिखा डबल कोट
डबल कोट मैंने क्या लिखा देन उसके बाद
डॉलर नेम और आपको जैसे एक बिगनर ऐसे लिखता
है उसका ग्रेटर देन सिंबल और उसके बाद
क्या करना है डबल कोड ल को मैंने टिट साइन
डे साइन य वाला उसके बाद प्रोड स्लश देन
मैंने क्या किया डॉलर आउट सिंपली मैंने
इसे लिखा और अपने स्क्रिप्ट को सेव करूंगा
और इसको एग्जीक्यूट करवा दूंगा क्योंकि
टास्क तो यही था कि जो यूजर ये यूजर नेम
है ये क्या है यूजर नेम का फर्स्ट नेम और
लास्ट नेम दोनों को सेपरेट करना है सेपरेट
करके इस फाइल के अंदर क्या करना है
अलग-अलग सेव करना है सचिन और सिंह दोनों
अलग-अलग सेव होने चाहिए इस फाइल के अंदर
उसके लिए आपको क्या करनी है एक स्क्रिप्ट
लिखनी है तो मैं लिखने के बजाय मैं क्या
कर रहा है इसको सेव करने इस रिडक कर रहा
हूं कमांड से टेस्ट कर रहा हूं तो मैंने
सिंपली ये बोला इतना इजी है लिखने के लिए
क्या प्रॉब्लम है अभी हम बिगिनर्स यहां पर
गलतिया करते हैं क्या गलतिया करते हैं अभी
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कि आपको स्क्रिप्ट
क्या लिखनी थ क्या आपको लगता है कि जो
आउटपुट मैंने आपको स्क्रिप्ट लिखने के लिए
दी थी या जो मैं आउटपुट आप लोग से चाहता
था जो एम था स्क्रिप्ट क्या य पर पूरा
होगा आपको क्या लगता है इसके अंदर जो एम
था वो पूरा होगा इसी को समझेंगे क्योंकि
पहले में इजी पार्ट है वो सब परफॉर्म हो
जाए आपको इसके अंदर क्या लगता है कि जो
आपका परफॉर्म होगा तो अब इसी के ऊपर सब
कुछ परफॉर्म करेंगे टोकेनाइजेशन भी और सब
कुछ हम इस परफॉर्म करने वाले देखो तो सबसे
पहले जो हमारा स्टेप परफॉर्म किया जाएगा
ये रहा तो सबसे पहले जो हमारा स्टेप होगा
यहां पर आपका परफॉर्म किया जाए
टोकेनाइजेशन स्टेप वन आप बिल्कुल ध्यान से
समझना स्टेप वन है जो आपका टोकेनाइजेशन
आज के बाद मैं दोबारा नहीं समझाने वाला
फिर मैं टोकेनाइजेशन स्टेप वन आपका
परफॉर्म किया
जाएगा
ओके तो टोकेनाइजेशन है ये आपका तो
टोकेनाइजेशन में अ फॉर एग्जांपल आप क्या
करोगे वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर को फाइंड आउट करना
पड़ता है ना तो यहां पर आपको क्या दिखाई
दे रहा है ट स्टेप में व तीन स्पेस है और
यहां पर जब मैं इसको टना परफॉर्म करता हूं
यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा एक के बाद स्पेस है
देन ये जो डबल कोट है डॉलर है ये सब आपका
क्या है मेटा कैरेक्टर्स के अंदर आता नहीं
तो अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर नहीं उसके बाद फिर
स्पेस है गरन सिंबल फ स्पेस है तो य पर
क्या है तीन स्पेस और ग्रेटर देन सिंबल है
ये तीन स्पेस और ये एक ग्रेटर देन सिंबल य
स्पेस है और यह ग्रेटर दन सिल फस स्पेस है
यह क्या आपका किसका पार्ट है यह है
अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर है तो इसने क्या कर
दिया आईडेंटिफाई कि आइडेंटी
फाइ
आइडेंटिफिकेशन स
एच अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स अब अनकोटेड
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स यहां पर कौन-कौन से हैं
एक तो है थ्री स्पेस थ्री स्पेस देन और
एंड और आपका क्या है एक है आपका ग्रेटर दन
सिंबल ग्रेटर देन सिंबल
ग्रेटर देन सिंबल ये आपका क्या है तीन
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है ग्रेटर दन सिंबल अगर
नहीं समझ में आ रहा हो तो ये रहा इसको हम
बोलेंगे ग्रेटर दन सिंबल ये है आपका ये
आपके और इसको एंड मैं सही से लिख देता हूं
ऐसे आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे अदर वाइज एंड ठीक
है तो ये आपका आइडेंटिफिकेशन
उसके बाद डबल कोट उसके बाद ल् साइन देन
फॉरवर्ड स्ल उसके बाद आपका जाता है डॉलर
आउट डॉलर आउट य आपका क्या है यह तीन क्या
वर्ड मैं अगर स्पेस थोड़ा देता एक य वर्ड
है उसके बाद य एक अपने वर्ड है य तीन क्या
है तीन वर्ड है उसके ऑपरेटर क्या है इसमें
एटी ऑपरेटर ऑपरेटर इसमें कौन सा है ऑपरेटर
एक ग्रेटर देन सिंबल है ग्रेटर देन सिंबल
है ग्रेटर दन सिंबल अब यह क्या ऑपरेटर्स
में डिवाइड हो ग मतलब मैंने यहां पे कर
दिया वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर में इसको एक बार
डिवाइड कर लिया नेक्स्ट आपका जा है अ
स्टेप वन परफॉर्म हो गया आपका स्टेप वन
मैंने क्या कर दिया यहां पर परफॉर्म कर
दिया स्टेप वन मैंने यहां पर परफॉर्म कर
दिया मैं इसको एक बार अब बात करते हैं
स्टेप टू की स्टेप टू यहां पर जो आपका
स्टेप टू है वह है टोकेनाइजेशन ओ स्टेप टू
है कमांड
एडिफिकेशन और सबको पता चल रहा हो कमांड
एडिफिकेशन में क्या सिंपल कंपाउंड है
कंपाउंड कमांड है और एक कमांड है या डबल
दो कमांड है अगर आप को बता पा रहे तो
बताइए जरा इसमें चैट में किसी को समझ में
आ रहा कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन अब यहां पर मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन कर रहा
हूं तो यह भी क्या है कि पहली बात तो
सिंपल कंपाउंड है कमांड है ये जो आपकी ये
है एक सिंपल कमांड है पहली बात ये सिंपल
कमांड है मैं इसको अगर आपको दिखाता हूं य
आपकी एक सिंपल कमांड है कैसे सिंपल कमांड
है ऊपर से क्या है कि क्या ये कमांड दो है
या एक है यह एक ही सिंपल कमांड है क्योंकि
जो ग्रेटर दन सिंबल है वोह कोई भी ऑपरेटर
नहीं है यह एक रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर है
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं है ओके एक कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर नहीं है जो कमांड टर्मिनेट होती है
कोई भी कमांड टर्मिनेट होती है वो कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर के बेसिस पर टर्मिनेट किया जाता है
किसी भी कमांड को और सिंपल क खासकर सिंपल
कमांड को सिंपल कमांड को टर्मिनेट कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर की हेल्प से ही टर्मिनेट किया जाता
है लेकिन यहां पर कोई भी कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
नहीं है रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर इसलिए इसको एक
ही सिंपल कमांड कंसीडर किया जाता है तो ये
क्या है एक सिंपल कमांड है ओनली येय अकेली
ही सिंपल कमांड है तो मैं इसके सामने लिख
देता हूं
वन सिंपल कमांड वन सिंपल कमांड है एज वल
ये पूरी पूरी क्या एक सिंपल कमांड है मैं
इसको वो कर देता हूं समझ में आ
जाएगा
य ये रहा ये वन सिंपल कमांड हो गया आपके
सामने अब बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट हम चलते
हैं इस पे कि आपका स्टेप टू भी कंफर्म हो
गया क्या हो गया परफॉर्म हो गया करते
स्टेप थ की बात करते हम स्टेप थ की स्टेप
थ स्टेप थ में आता
आपका स्टेप थ्री में आता है
एक्सपेंशन एक्सपेंशन इसके परफॉर्म कि
जाएंगे एक्सपेंशन आपको चार स्टेज में होते
हैं आपको ऑलरेडी पता है तो आपको क्या लगता
है य पर की इसके अंदर कोई ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म हो रहा है या यहां पर कोई भी
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन है तो यहां पर नो ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन ब्रेस एक्स प ए एन एस नो ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन कोई भी ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन नहीं है
ने बात करते इस स्टेज टू स्टेज टू में
क्या है क्या आपको लगता है य पर कोई भी
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है कुछ भी है यस य पर
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है तो अब मैं वन बाय
वन करता हूं इधर देखो य पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन क ये रहा ये पैरामीटर है नेम और
आउट दोनों पैरामीटर है तो य पर पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो रहा है तो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो रहा था तो यहां पर
क्या आ रहा है एक उसके बाद आ रहा है डॉलर
नेम की जगह ये इसके अंदर डबल कोट के अंदर
आ रहा है सचिन सचिन डॉट सिंह एसई एंड जीएच
सिं ये आ रहा है नेक्स्ट मैं अभी अभी उसको
दिखा नहीं रहा उसके बाद ग्रेटर देन सिंबल
देन उसके बाद डबल कोट उसके बाद ग्रेटर देन
टिल डेट सिंबल देन फव स्ल डॉलर आउट ऐसे ही
लिख रहा हूं पहले मैं एक चीज परफॉर्म करके
दिखा रहा हूं ये रहा अभी मैंने आपको
दिखाया इसने क्या कर दिया पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन था क्योंकि दो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हो वैसे पहला पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म कर दिया तो उसकी जो
वैल्यू थी सचिन डॉट सिंह थी क्योंकि यहां
पर पैरामीटर क्या है नेम है नेम को
रिप्लेस कर दिया इसने डॉलर नेम को रिप्लेस
कर दिया किसके साथ इसके साथ सचिन डॉट सिंह
अभी एक चीज तो यहां पर ये होगी दूसरा एक
चीज बताइए मेरे को की पटर एक्सशन परफॉर्म
हो रहा है एक य पर टड एक्सपेंशन य पर एक
टड एक्सपेंशन भी है य तो यह क्या था देखो
यह पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन था यह आपका इ
एक्सपेंशन है और यह आपका क्या
है ये आपका क्या है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है
य ओनली य रहा यहां पर ये ओनली पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन है अब मुझे एक चीज बताइए कोई
कि यह जो डेड एक्सपेंशन है क्या ये
परफॉर्म होगा यहां पर किसी को
अगर किसी को य किसी को लगता है कि यहां पर
टिल डेड एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म
होगा आपको लग रहा टि एक्सपें परफॉर्म होगा
नहीं लडी एक्सपेंशन इसलिए परफॉर्म नहीं
होगा क्योंकि यहां पर डबल कोट है और डबल
कोट का आपको पता है कि कोटिंग के दौरान जो
डबल कोट है सभी कैरेक्टर्स का स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव कर देता है एक्सेप्ट डॉलर
सिंबल और बैकटिक सिंबल एक्सेप्ट डॉलर एंड
बैकटिक सिंबल यहां पर क्या है डॉलर सिंबल
है ओके यहां पर इसका तो स्पेशल मीनिंग
परफॉर्म होगा बट इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग
परफॉर्म नहीं होगा लेकिन मैं क्या चाहता
था होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर स्टोर करना
चाहता था मैं अपना होम डायरेक्ट अंदर
स्टोर करना चाहता था अभी फिर ये कैसे आएगा
अभी यह नीचे ऐसे लिखा जाएगा ए देन डबल कोट
उसके बाद सचिन डॉट एस आई एनजी एच सि देन
ग्रेटर देन सिंबल नेक्स्ट ये रहा डबल कोट
उसके बाद टिल डेट सिंबल ऐसे ही रहेगा उसके
बाद फ फॉरवर्ड स्लैश देन डॉलर आउटपुट की
जगह क्या लिखा जाएगा आपका आउटपुट आउटपुट
डॉटी एक्सटी आ जाएगा आउटपुट डटी एक्सटी आ
जाएगा क्योंकि पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन य
परफॉर्म हो गया क्योंकि डॉलर यहां पर अपना
काम कर इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग यहां पे रिमूव
नहीं होस ये क्या फॉरवर्ड स्लैश है ना कि
बैक स्लैश है अब यहां पर यहां तक तो हो
गया ये अभी आपको एक चीज बताता हूं मैं
यहां पर देन यहां पर कोई भी अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म नहीं हो रहा है कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन परफॉर्म नहीं हो रहा है मतलब
स्टेप थ्री कंप्लीट हो गया स्टेप थ्री
स्टेप थ्री कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ उसके हां
स्टेप थ्री यहां पर कंप्लीट हो गया कोई भी
अब सॉरी सॉरी स्टेप थ्री परफॉर्म कंप्लीट
नहीं हुआ स्टेप थ्री का जो स्टेज थ्री है
वो आ गया अब यहां स्टेज थ्री की बात करते
हैं ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन नहीं था पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हो गया अब यहां पर बात करें हम
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग जो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग एस पी
एल आई टी आई ए वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग यहां पर
क्या वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म होगी या
नहीं होगी वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग यहां पर क्या
परफॉर्म होगी या नहीं होगी अभी इधर वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग की बात करते क्योंकि जो मेरा
एम था स्क्रिप्ट का वो एम आपको फुलफिल
करना है क्योंकि जो सचिन डॉट सिंह है
क्योंकि आईस वेरिएबल की वैल्यू मैंने क्या
कर दिया डॉट कर दिया ना मैं चाहता हूं
सचिन और सिंह दोनों अलग-अलग जाके इसके
अंदर स्टोर हो जाए फर्स्ट नेम और लास्ट
नेम दोनों अलग-अलग जाके स्टोर हो जाए
लेकिन यहां पर प्रॉब्लम क्या आई देखो यहां
पर प्रॉब्लम यह आई कि जब मुझे क्या करना
था फुल स्टॉप के बेसिस पर क्या करना था
स्प्लिट करना था वर्ड्स को सचिन और सिंह
को दोनों को अलग-अलग परफॉर्म करना था बट
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग क्या बोलता है वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग क्या बोलता है कि भैया मैं
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म करूंगा किसके आ
आउटपुट के ऊपर पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन और अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन ठीक है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है
उसका आउटपुट है उसके परफॉर्म करूंगा बट
उसकी कंडीशन क्या है कि वो अनकोटेड होना
चाहिए अनकोटेड मतलब वो कोट नहीं होना
चाहिए मतलब उस व उसका जो आउटपुट है वो
किसी बैक स्लैश या डबल कोट सिंगल कोट के
अंदर नहीं होना चाहिए लेकिन यहां पर क्या
है प्रॉब्लम ये आई कि यहां पर वर्ड
स्पिटिंग काम नहीं कर रहा इसके ऊपर इसके
ऊपर व स्प्लिटिंग काम नहीं करेगा क्योंकि
ये कोटेड है नेक्स्ट अब एक अच्छी चीज भी
हुई अच्छी चीज ये हुई कि मैं क्या चाहता
था कि जो मेरा आउटपुट है वो इसके अंदर ही
शे होना चाहिए ना आउटपुट डटी एक्सटी
आउटपुट टी एक्सटी के अंदर ही सेव होना
चाहिए अच्छी चीज य हो कि मैंने इसको डबल
कोट के अंदर दे रखा था जब मैंने इसको डबल
कोट के अंदर दे रखा था तो क्या हुआ यहां
पर वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म नहीं हुआ वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म नहीं हुआ तो मेरा
आउटपुट ड एक्सटी स्प्लिट होने से बच गया
तो क्योंकि जो मेरा सीन और सिं दोनों
दोनों जो वर्ड्स है वो इसके अंदर जाने
चाहिए आउटपुट डॉटी एक्सटी के अंदर लेकिन
अगर मैं इनको डबल कोट के अंदर नहीं देता
तो आउटपुट डटी एक्सटी क्या होते हैं आपके
सेपरेट हो जाते है मतलब एक अच्छी चीज हुई
एक खराब चीज हुई तो मुझे इसको ठीक करना
होगा क्योंकि जो मैंने जो चीज समझ ग मैंने
कोड को लिखा था वो यहां पर गलत हो गया
क्योंकि मैंने कोड को लिखा था ऐसे कोड को
मैंने ये ऐसे ही लिखा था डॉलर नेम बट भैया
आप लोगों को लगा कि मैंने सही लिखा है
लेकिन हमने गलती यहां पर की मुझे स्प्लिट
करना है लिटिंग परफॉर्म करने के लिए मुझे
क्या करना पड़ेगा यहां पर इसको सचिन डट
सिंह है इस वाली प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व करना पड़े
इस वाली प्रॉब्लम को मुझे सॉल्व करना है
तो मुझे इसको कैसे करना होगा मुझे इसको
लिखना होगा
एक डॉलर उसके बाद नेम ऐसे लिखना चाहिए था
मुझे उसके ग्रेटर देन सिंबल ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल और जो वो एज इट इज रहेगा देन उसके
बाद जो मेरा डॉलर येट सपल उसके बाद आउ
डॉलर आउट डॉलर यटी आउट जब मैं अपनी कमांड
को ऐसे लिखता इस वाली कमांड को जब मैं
इसको अपनी कमांड को ऐसे लिखता तो जो मैं
चाहता हूं आउटपुट वैसा ही आता है क्योंकि
एक अच्छी चीज हु थ एक बुरी चीज अच्छी चीज
तो ठीक है ये मेरा सही हुआ तो ये मुझे ऐसे
ही रखना है दूसरा डॉलर नेम तो अब इस
कंडीशन को फुल फिल करूंगा तो यहां पर क्या
आएगा अब मुझे जो जब वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
परफॉर्म होगी क्योंकि जब स्टेज थ्री आ रहा
था आपका इसके अंदर जब कोनाइजेशन हुआ कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन हुआ एक्सपेंशन हुआ उसके बाद
यहां पर क्या आएगा एक देन डॉलर नेम की जगह
आएगा सचिन डॉट उसके बाद सिं यहां पर देन
गय ग्रेटर दन सिंबल उसके बाद ये उसके बाद
टल डेट सिंबल फ स्ल य पर आउटपुट डॉटी एक्स
मुझे ऐसा ही चाहिए था बट मेरी कंडीशन एक
और थी जो ये जो इसका जो सचिन ड सचिन और
सिंह दोनों अलग अलग वर्ड स्प्लिट होके आ
ये कहां पर सेव होनी चाहिए मेरी कहां पर
ये सेव होनी चाहिए मेरी होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि बार-बार
मैं हर यूजर्स की होम डायरेक्टरी तो
लिखूंगा नहीं क्योंकि स्क्रिप्ट तो मेरी
ऐसी होनी चाहिए कि जहां पर रन कर उसी होम
डायरेक्टरी में परफॉर्म क होम डायरेक्ट के
ऊप परमिशन होती है हर एक यूजर्स को बाकी
जो में किसी को कहीं परमिशन नहीं होती तोब
इस प्रॉब्लम को कैसे मैं सॉल्व करूं देखो
मैं डबल कोट को हटा नहीं सकता डबल कोट को
हटा नहीं सकता हूं क्योंकि इसके ऊपर वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म कर जाएगा स्न डट ब
यहां पर वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म नहीं
करेगा लेकिन दूसरी समस्या यहां पर ये आई
टिल डेट एक्सपेंशन कैसे परफॉर्म करवाऊं तो
भया डबल कोट तो मुझे लगाना ही पड़ेगा डबल
कोट नहीं लगाऊंगा तो यहां पर फिर ये वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग हो जाएगी तो मुझे वड
स्प्लिटिंग को रोकना है ठीक है वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग को रोक दि टिल डेड एक्सपेंशन
का क्या सोल्यूशन निकालू मैं यहां पर टिल
डेट एक्सपेंशन का सोल्यूशन ये है मुझे
क्या करना होगा यहां पर इसका भी सोल्यूशन
क्या है फिर से मुझे अपनी कमांड को कैसे
लिखना होता इस कमांड को मुझे लिखना पड़ता
ऐसे कंट्रोल सी उसके बाद य कंट्रोल व देन
मैं इसको टड एक्सपें मुझे लिखना होता डॉलर
होम क्योंकि डॉलर होम जो वेरिएबल है ये भी
तो वही काम करता है ना टिट एक्सपेंशन की
जगह डलर हो भी वही काम करता है डबल कोट के
अंदर क्योंकि स्प्लिटिंग मुझे परफॉर्म
नहीं करनी है उसके बाद क्या है होम ड्राइव
के अंदर स्टोर करना है डलर होम जो वेरिएबल
होता है एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल होता है
सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल होता है वो भी
किसी भी यूजर्स की होम डायरेक्टरी को
स्टोर करके रखता है तो अभी जो मुझे कोड
लिखना था ये परफेक्ट कोड लिखा मैंने अभी
जो मेरा ये कोड होना चाहिए मुझे परफेक्ट
कोड लिख कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और मेरा यह
मेरा वो परफेक्ट कोड है अभी तक मैं जो कोड
लिखने वाला था वो गलत लिख रहा था ये है
मेरा अभी तक का परफेक्ट कोड कंट्रोल v ये
है वो परफेक्ट कोड जो आपको लिखना था जिन
कंडीशन के साथ परफेक्ट कोड लिखना था ये है
आपका परफेक्ट कोड अभी तक गलतियों के साथ
कर रहे थे आप ऐसे ही आपकी छोटी-छोटी गलती
होती जो बाद में आपको पता नहीं चलता और
एरर आपको आती रहती है और आपका डिजायर्ड
आउटपुट आता नहीं तो यहां तक क्या हुआ आपका
परफॉर्म हो गया अभी जो आउटपुट आपको देखने
को मिलेगा देखो अभी जो आउटपुट आपको देखने
को मिलेगा मैं क्या कर रहा हूं कंट्रोल सी
देन कंट्रोल व ये रहा अभी जो यहां पर क्या
है यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा क्या
यहां पर मिलेगी जैसे मैंने लिखा
होम हो और मेरी ही डायरेक्टरी है फॉर
एग्जांपल ये काली लिखा मैंने काली की ही
होम डायरेक्टरी है तो इस तरीके से अभी
आएगा ये इसके अंदर अभी यहां पर हो गया
मतलब अभी यहां पर वड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म
होगा अब यहां पर वड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म
होगा इसके परर जब ये वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
परफॉर्म हो जाएगा आपको क्या लगता है व
स्लिटिंग के बाद क्या
इस ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म हो गया नहीं अब इसके
ऊपर नो ग्लोबिंग नो ग्लोबिंग कोई भी
ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म नहीं होगी तो स्टेप थ्री
आपका कंप्लीट हो गया स्टेप थ्री के बाद
में आपका क्या आएगा स्टेप फोर स्टेप फोर आ
रहा है स्टेप फोर में आपका क्या है कोट
रिमूवल कोट रिमूवल आर ई एम ओवी ए कोट
रिमूवल की भी कंडीशन आपको पता है जो कोट
रिमूवल क्या होते है उन्हीं के कोट रिमूवल
जो अन कोटेड बैक स्लेस सिंगल कोट डबल कोट
अभ ठीक है आ जाते इसको ले आते हैं अब हम
इसके ऊपर कोट रिमूव होगा ना बाकी के तो
ऊपर होगा नहीं कंट्रोल सी और इसको क्या
करता कंट्रोल इधर लिखता हूं तो देखो अभी
इसका तो कोई रोल ही नहीं है व स्प्लिटिंग
परफॉर्म होगी अलग अलग इनको कर दिया ठीक है
इनको अलग अलग कर दिया इसने अब कोट रिमूवल
की बात आ रही है क्योंकि ये परफॉर्म हो
गया डॉट बेस सेपरेट कर लेगा अब बात कर रहे
हैं हम यहां पर कोट रिमोल की बात कर रहे
हैं हां इसको मैं क्या करता हूं एकम स्पेस
कर दिया इनको ठीक है अभी इसकी बात कर रहा
हूं अब कोट रिमूवल क्या यहां पर कोट
रिमूवल परफॉर्म होगा होगा क्योंकि देखो
आपका कोट रिमूवल परफॉर्म होहुआ है लेकिन
किसके ऊपर ओनली इसके ऊपर ओनली इसके ऊपर
यही है कोट रिमूवल आपका परफॉर्म होगा आपका
कोट रिमूवल परफॉर्म होगा क्योंकि पहली बात
तो वो अनकोटेड होना चाहिए जो आपका डबल कोट
है यहां पर अनकोटेड है और ये कभी किसी भी
उसका पार्ट नहीं है किसी के भी जो
एक्सपेंशन है उसका आउटपुट का पार्ट नहीं
है क्योंकि ऑलरेडी यहां पर पहले से ही ये
कोर्ट के अंदर था तो आप क्या हुआ अब उसकी
जो कंडीशन थी कोर्ट रिल की इसने फुलफिल कर
दी तो आपका आएगा
एकको सचिन स्पेस सेपरेटेड सिं क्योंकि
अलग-अलग हो है ग्रेटर देन सिंबल देन य
पैसे आएगा कोट रिमोल होने के बाद कोट
रिमोल हो गया होम उसके बाद काली देन उसके
बाद आउटपुट डॉट t एकटी देन ये हो गया आपका
आपकी फाइनल स्टेटमेंट ये बन गई उसका जो
परफॉर्म होगा और उसके बाद क्या हो स्टेप
फाइव होगा उसके बाद आपका क्या परफॉर्म
होगा स्टेप फाइव स्टेप फाइव में क्या है
रीडायरेक्शन रीडायरेक्शन में क्या होगा
आपका जो आउटपुट होगा वो आपका इसके अंदर
आके स्टोर हो जाएगा जो आपका आउटपुट होगा
वो इसके अंदर आके स्टोर हो जाएगा आउटपुट
एक्टी के अंदर जैसा आप चाहिए था आपको क्या
करना था सचिन और सिंह का लास्ट नेम और
फर्स्ट नेम को दोनों अलग-अलग करना था और
यूजर्स की होम डायरेक्ट के अंदर एक आउटपुट
नाम की जो फाइल थी उसके अंदर स्टोर स्टोर
हो जाए वो हो गया तो यह थे आपके वो पांच
स्टेप तो आई होप की दो एग्जांपल के साथ
मैं समझाने की कोशिश कर आपको बेहतरीन
तरीके से समझ में आ गया होगा स्टिल अगर
किसी को कोई लगता है कि मेरा डाउट है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकता है फ मिनट फॉर डाउट सेशन
अभी अभी देख लीजिए एक बार
य
यह पांच ये थही आपकी पांच स्टेप्स कैसे
कैसे परफॉर्म हुआ तो इस तरीके से अगर आप
सोच सोच के अगर आपको लगता है कहीं पर जैसा
आउटपुट आपको सही नहीं आ रहा है तो आपको एक
बार इन पांच स्टेप को ध्यान में रखना है
कि हां मैं कहां पर गलती कर रहा हूं मेरी
उसके
अंदर स्क्रिप्टिंग के अंदर हो सकता है कि
आप ऐसी कोई गलती कर रहे हो जैसे अभी कर
रहे थे आपने क्या कर दिया था कि इसको डबल
कोट्स के अंदर दे दिया था और यहां पर टिल
डेट साइन कर दिया था अगर आपको ये कांसेप्ट
नहीं पता होता हाउ बेस्ट प्रोसेस कमांड
लाइन तो डेफिनेटली आप क्या करते ग करते
रहते ग के बेसिस पर आप ए रिजॉल्व कर लेते
डीब कर लेते बट आपको पता नहीं रहता कि
रिजॉल्व कैसे हुई है क्योंकि बिहाइंड द
सीन आपको पता नहीं कि कमांड कैसे काम कर
रही है कैसे उसको बेस्ट प्रोसेस कर रहा है
जब इन पांच स्टेप्स के बारे में आपको पता
चल जाएगा तो आपकी जो डीब डीबगिंग पावर है
उसको भी एक एक्स्ट्रा पावर मिल जाती है और
आपको क्या है खुद से ही अपने कोड को डीब
कर पाओगे और एरर लेस आप कोड लिख पाओगे आज
के बाद तो यही था आपका कमांड लाइन
प्रोसेसिंग
देन अगर अभी कोई स्टिल कोई डाउट है तो पूछ
सकता
[प्रशंसा]
है फ मिनट फॉर डाउट
सेशन
ब
इट्स ओके फिर देर नो डाउट तो सेशन को एंड
करते हैं तो बाय बाय गुड डे टेक केयर सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन